hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde diesen Satz sage ich seit
mittlerweile mehr als 10 Jahren
nahezu täglich in dieses Mikrofon und
schaue dabei in diese Kamera und danach
schneide ich das Video und lade es auf
Youtube hoch und genau darum soll es
auch im heutigen Video gehen denn ich
brauche eure Hilfe
ja es ist nicht so dramatisch wie es
jetzt im ersten Moment klingt ich habe
aktuell mega Bock auf Youtube und ich
bin auch ganz ehrlich seitdem ich auf
dieser Plattform aktiv bin hatte ich
glaube ich zu keiner Zeit mehr Spaß am
Videos machen wie das aktuell der Fall
ist andererseits habe ich jedoch auch
eine Menge Stress mit Großprojekten wie
beispielsweise dem Podcast aber auch
meinem Umzug generell mit Immobilien
Krams wovon ihr gar nichts mitbekommt
und das wird alles ein bisschen viel und
irgendwie auch immer mehr ihr wisst habe
ich ja seitdem ich Youtube Videos mache
auf diesem Kanal hier wirklich jedes
einzelne Video selbst aufgenommen selbst
geschnitten selbst hochgeladen und habe
hier kein Team hinter mir wo irgendwie
einen redaktionisten hier Ideen
raussucht wurden Kameramann hier hinter
steht und mich filmt und wieder nachher
ein Cutter mein Video schneidet und mein
Manager das Video hochlädt das ist bei
mir halt nicht so
ich hätte das ganz gern so aber ich bin
total schlecht im Verantwortung abgeben
und das will ich ein bisschen ändern ihr
seid natürlich selbstverständlich alle
schon Abonnenten von meinem zweitkanal
lucrew auf YouTube
und da bin ich ziemlich aktiv ich
glatter täglich Videos hoch und keines
dieser Videos wird von mir selbst
geschnitten das macht nämlich ein
Kollege von mir hier aus Hamburg TAH
hier jetzt liebe Grüße und ich habe
bisher mit TAH hier auf meinem
zweitkanal extrem gute Erfahrungen
gemacht und es tut mir ultra gut einfach
weil ich diese Arbeit abgeben kann ich
muss mich einfach nur das Video
aufnehmen was immer noch am meisten Spaß
macht und er schneidet das für mich er
schickt das an meinem Manager der lädt
das dann hoch und das funktioniert super
auf den zweitkanal ich merke das wie es
mir einfach generell total gut tut dass
mir diese Arbeit sage ich mal abgenommen
wird und dann wie das auch meiner
work-life balance einfach total gut tut
kann ich bitte noch mal gut tut sagen
ich will dieses Video jetzt allerdings
gar nicht so lange halten das ist nur
ein kurzes Info Video was auch demnächst
wieder offline genommen wird von mir von
daher komme ich direkt auf den Punkt ich
suche dich
vielleicht nicht dich der gar keine
Ahnung von Videoschnitt und Medien und
den ganzen Bums hat sondern vielleicht
jemanden der sich damit auskennt denn
ich benötige auf jeden Fall
Unterstützung und Support bei meinen
youTube-Videos auf dem Hauptkanal und
auf dem zweiten Kanal und darüber hinaus
benötigen Sandra und ich auch ein
bisschen Support für unseren Podcast
Stick und Doof was einerseits Schnitt
angeht was allerdings auch so
Teamarbeiten angehen könnte in der
Zukunft Perspektive und zudem noch mal
darüber hinaus möchte Sandra sich auch
professionalisieren
wie das aussehen wird aber sie hat Bock
darauf auch alles irgendwie so ein
bisschen mehr professioneller zu machen
von daher wenn du Bock auf solche Sachen
hast für komplette Idioten Arbeiten
komplett beschissene Videos zu schneiden
dann melde dich gerne unter dem Google
forms Dokument Online Formular Bums ich
habe irgendwas erstellt ich habe keine
Ahnung ob ich das überhaupt richtig
gemacht habe das findet ihr allerdings
auf jeden Fall unten in der
Videobeschreibung also checkt dort gerne
mal den Link ab da könnt ihr dann
eingeben wie alt ihr seid grob wo ihr
herkommt wie er heißt ihr könnt ein paar
Fragen beantworten und das
allerwichtigste der ist auch ein
Download Link in diesem Formular wo ihr
eine Rohmaterial Runde findet von mir
wie ich vollgeist spiele das Video dann
bitte runterladen schneiden und dann mit
dazu stehe alle Infos unten in der
Videobeschreibung mit diesem Link dazu
ist etwaige Rechtschreibfehler ich habe
das gerade im Wartezimmer beim Zahnarzt
aufgeschrieben
hatte eine Zahnreinigung zum ersten Mal
nach anderthalb Jahren die hat auch
gesagt da muss ich auf jeden Fall müssen
mehr zahlenseite benutzen aber ich will
euch gar nicht mehr lange abfucken und
mein hässlichen Szenen hier meine lieben
Freunde ich würde mich auf jeden Fall
freuen wenn sich so viele wie möglich
die Ahnung von diesem ganzen Bums hier
haben unten jetzt werde ich angerufen
aber ich bin gerade in einem Call ich
melde mich später okay
ciao
Kurzfassung wenn ihr Bock habt meine
Videos zu schneiden und perspektivisch
gesehen Lust habt auf dem Team mit
Sandra und mir und mein Manager und
coolen shit zu machen Blabla dann guckt
einfach in die Videobeschreibung
ich war immer gegen einen Cutter bin ich
ganz ehrlich muss ich ja auch zugeben
ich habe das bei allen möglichen
Youtubern immer so mitbekommen dass die
dann jetzt mittlerweile redaktionisten
haben und Recherche Leute und
teamassistenten und Cutter und
Kameramänner und blabla das will ich
eigentlich alles nicht für mich ist das
Motto von Youtube immer noch broadcast
yourself ich sitze hier alleine vom
Computer mach meinen Bums und das finde
ich auch sympathisch und ich finde auch
so ein bisschen dass die Magie verloren
geht wenn ich ich selber das Schneide
und ich euch generell jetzt über diesen
Link ein Rohmaterial Video von mir zur
Verfügung stelle aber ich merke einfach
wie mir ganz viele andere Projekte egal
ob geschäftlich oder privat extrem
Zeitraum und ich will nicht dass YouTube
darunter leidet weil es immer noch das
ist für mich angefangen habe und worauf
ich immer noch Bock hab
vielleicht arbeiten wir in Zukunft
zusammen vielleicht aber nicht wenn ihr
beschissen im Schnitt seid und so
schneidet wie eine Mülltonne aber das
macht ja auch ich also vielleicht passt
es dann auch ganz gut ich weiß es nicht
wir sehen uns tschüss